[Music]
Donald Trump won big last night on Super
Tuesday
one story a lot of people were talking
about today is Chris Christie's face
during Trump's victory speech last night
Christie if you saw it he had a really
zoned out expression on his face he
looked like he wasn't entirely
comfortable standing behind Trump he
almost looked like he was in a hostage
situation everybody's talking about it
today take a look this has been an
amazing evening so I congratulate it was
an excellent win why hasn't she done
practically everything that she was
complaining about she's picked up what I
say no way it almost it almost makes you
feel bad for Chris Christie doesn't it I
mean he's clearly standing beside
someone he loathes with every fiber of
his being
[Applause]
the guy made a commitment he made a
commitment now he has to support this
belligerent madman
he probably check it out
he probably at one time probably thought
it would be good for his career little
did he know it would take him nowhere
yeah now now the guys realizing he
hitched his wagon to a morally bankrupt
creep or maybe he's just fascinated with
that blowhards ridiculous hair
that's hair that defies logic it's a
national punchline and how does someone
sleep at night knowing he's compromised
his core values by teaming up with the
devil himself I have no idea it's
ridiculous
oh hey hey Amy what are you doing there
just supporting a great great man
[Applause]
we got the star of Borat Borat Bruno and
the new movie I saw it it's hilarious
the brothers Grimsby Sacha Baron Cohen
is
[Applause]
comedian Jimmy Pardo I love that guy
he's a good man music guests parquet
courts they're here
coming up at Gino
you